this week we're talking with a
self-proclaimed normal American
millennial who grew up in America all
his life
Johnny young thank you for being here
Johnny young thanks Chris I love text
I left Netflix and chill dawg spell da
WG the young way okay great well that
kills any suspicions I might have had
right what do you think about Russia's
alleged interference in our election hey
chill out man
Russia has nothing to do with that but
zynga first of all please don't ever say
that again and they don't know no Chris
you've been smoking too much of that
sticky-icky which I which I as an
American Alania all seen joy to smoke
and relax with my young friends
bad
please
thank you for ceasing your DAB according
to Fortune magazine though Russian
hackers are believed to be responsible
for obtaining 19 thousand private emails
from the Democratic Party you're still
using email oh man
the new cool thing is snapchat you can
set secret messages to everyone of your
millennium friends who have infiltrated
every level of American government and
the messages automatically self-destruct
blast their filters to make you look
like a bunny the country
I'm not trying to be a dick but you
sound like an older Eastern European man
and you look like you run a pager store
oh I'm from New Jersey
it's my hipster beard confusing you I
don't know jack we pull up this guy's
credentials please I'm not sure Johnny's
the real deal what are you doing on your
phone
that shows difficulty
epic fail
I run back
why are you calling out a deceased
gorilla name and hacking my show at the
same time I think this comic really kind
of dangerous there Vladimir Putin's
points now no that's it you know
something you stop that clapping you
know you can put the presidential
election fine but don't you dare for the
integrity of the game portion of
@midnight you son of a bitch get out of
here you Russian spy Oh Russian spy
everyone stop dabbing don't let him have
any more